now to constant swoop because we're
learning all about her personal and
professional pain in her new book making
a scene Constance taking it a step
further bringing her truth to the red
table
during my first couple years on Fresh
Off The Boat I was
um sexually harassed and I was
intimidated and I was threatened all the
time
the actual touching of me it only
happened once it was him rubbing my leg
and being like your skin is so smooth
and me being like stop don't do that and
then him going further and putting his
hand over my crotch
emotional and in tears Constance goes
into detail about the unnamed producer
she claims violated her while she
struggled with that privately Constance
later faced public backlash for tweets
which have now been deleted that
expressed her frustration over the
renewal of fresh off the boat the first
sitcom to feature an Asian-American
family in 20 years people are basically
canceling me for being ungrateful and
ungraceful I read these DMS from an
Asian actress I felt like
the only thing that would prove to her
that I felt as bad as she thought I
deserved to feel would would be if I
died
in her Memoir making a scene the 40 year
old goes into detail about her suicide
attempt admitting she felt helpless and
desperate which led her to the edge of
her fifth floor balcony a friend who had
come to check on me pulled me over
from climbing over the ledge and took me
to a psychiatric emergency room I had to
be in therapy with a psychiatrist and a
psychologist every day for a while and
it was just such a lonely place to meet
after a three-year Hiatus Constance is
now returning to the spotlight her red
table talk is streaming now on Facebook
watch and her film Lyle Lyle Crocodile
hits theaters Friday does it feel good
to be back in Action yeah it feels right
I feel more authentic let's go over here
[Music]